the parents of one of our Kelly's
live-in girlfriends tell CBS this
morning they are making progress toward
their first face-to-face meeting with
her in more than two years Joycelyn
savages mother pleaded to Kelly
yesterday to let her see her daughter
she believes that Joycelyn has been
brainwashed
Jericka Duncan is in Chicago where our
Kelly lives dareka good morning good
morning the last time that we saw
Joycelyn savage was actually inside this
Trump Tower high-rise Gail where you did
the interview with her it was there that
she said that she is staying with Kelly
willingly and maintains that she's
staying there because she loves him
I have no doubt that you have phillies
are mr. Kelly John Jolin Savage has
resorted to holding news conferences in
order to communicate with her 23 year
old daughter Joycelyn she says the last
time she saw her was two and a half
years ago
Jocelyn if you do hear my message please
know that your mother loves you dearly
all the lies manipulation things that
you've heard about your family that we
took money that we don't want to see you
those are all lies Gerald Griggs this
savage family's attorney says Kelly's
crisis manager Darrell Johnson told him
last week a meeting between Joycelyn and
her family was eminent if she decides
willingly to leave mr. Robert Sylvester
Kelly that's on her but we want to
establish a relationship back with her
family and then move from there in a
television interview last night Johnson
laid out possible conditions for the
meeting we'd have maybe one camera a
mediator not to just let them do what
they do and so on that's it and just
listen and when it's over perhaps
interview each participant dare say you
know what you get out of it you know
everybody got what they wanted last week
Joycelyn savage made a surprise phone
call to her family how will we know
you're happy when we are here from year
two years
I love you Jules me that call came the
day after she and Kelly's other live-in
girlfriend Azrael Clary gave an
exclusive interview to Gayle King with
Kelly listening nearby both women
claimed their parents were scammers out
to get money from the three-time Grammy
winner I'm very free well to make my own
decisions and I choose to be here with
Robert and you both have made the
decision that you don't want to see your
families yes of course of course
Kelly adamantly denies holding any woman
against her will
you're saying the the parents handed
their daughters as well and Jocelyn over
to you is that what you're saying to her
absolutely the parents of both girls say
that they never asked our Kelly for any
money now joy since mom says she's
willing to have this meeting but she
does not want our Kelly present
meanwhile our Kelly pleaded not guilty
to aggravated criminal sexual abuse last
month and if he's convicted on all
charges Gail he is facing up to 70 years
in prison
Nora H arica thank you tomorrow we will
hear from Angelo and Alice Clary they're
their parents of are Kelly's other
live-in girlfriend her name is Asher l
Clary she told us last week that her
parents are just out for money that's
tomorrow
only on CBS this is just such a sad saga
guys all the way around there are no
winners here as I can see and the more
you hear about the story the more sad
and tragic it becomes it's just you just
want it all to end you want it all to
end but very gesture looks like there is
going to be a meeting this week so that
is very encouraging yeah the girls and
their families